This is 99% invisible. I am Roman Mars. Today's show is about a design flaw that might be, and I'm not exaggerating here, the single most common design flaw in human history. It potentially affects everything we have ever built. Its consequences are felt by more than half of people worldwide, and most people don't even notice it. But that's changing, thanks in no small part to the work of one woman. My name's Caroline Criado-Perez. I am a writer and activist who has written an incredible book. My book is called Invisible Women Exposing Data Biasts. No, wait, sorry, that's the British title.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。今天的节目要讲的是一个设计缺陷，而且我这话绝非夸大，它可能是人类历史上最普遍的设计缺陷。它可能影响了我们建造过的所有事物。全球超过一半的人都在承受其带来的后果，但大多数人甚至都没有注意到这一点。不过这种情况正在改变，这在很大程度上要归功于一位女性的工作。我叫卡罗琳·克里亚多·佩雷斯。我是一名作家兼活动家，写过一本不可思议的书。我的书名叫《被隐形的女性：暴露在专为男性设计的数据偏见中的世界》。不，等等，抱歉，那是英国书名。
What the f*** is the American title? The copy I have is called Invisible Women, data bias in a world designed for men. I know that British people swam more than American people. Is this a non-swery podcast? Well, you can swear all you like. We will probably bleep it. OK, I'll try to keep it to a minimum. And honestly, Caroline Criado Perez has good reason to swear,
美国书名到底是个啥？我手上的这本叫《被隐形的女性：数据偏见如何塑造了一个专为男性设计的世界》。我知道英国人比美国人更喜欢说脏话。这是个不能说脏话的播客吗？哦，你想说多少脏话都行。我们可能会消音处理。好吧，我尽量少说点。说实话，卡罗琳·克里亚多·佩雷斯确实有理由爆粗口，
because this design flaw, in addition to being everywhere, is really annoying. But like so many of the worst design flaws, it can be hard to notice at first. To demonstrate just how hard Caroline started off by telling me a story that begins with a joke about gender. So basically, in this town called Costco, Goga and Sweden, they were doing a gender analysis of all their local town policies and someone said, well obviously, snow clearing won't have anything to do with gender. And it does sound on the face of it ridiculous, how can snow clearing have
因为这个设计缺陷除了无处不在之外，还非常烦人。但就像许多最糟糕的设计缺陷一样，起初很难注意到它。为了说明这有多难，卡罗琳首先给我讲了一个以一个关于性别的笑话开头的故事。所以基本上，在瑞典卡尔斯库加这个小镇，他们正在对所有当地城镇政策进行性别分析，有人说，很明显，除雪工作跟性别八竿子打打不着。表面听起来确实挺荒谬的，除雪怎么会
anything to do with gender? After all, the city of Krollsgoga plowed its streets the way you'd think all cities would plow their streets, starting with the major arteries followed by local roads and sidewalks. It seemed about as genderless as you could get. But actually, it turned out this was heavily related to gender because male and female travel patterns are not the same. Men are far more likely to travel in a fairly simple way, using a car for a twice daily commute in and out of the city center.
跟性别有任何关系呢？毕竟，卡尔斯库加市清理街道的方式正如你想象中所有城市清理街道的方式一样，先清理主干道，然后是地方道路和人行道。这看起来似乎是再“无性别差异”不过了。但事实上，事实证明这与性别密切相关，因为男性和女性的出行模式并不相同。男性更有可能以相当简单的方式出行，即每天开车上下班两次，往返于市中心。
You can see this in the way that most cities are laid out, with major arteries going in and out of downtown, in what's called an arterial system, which makes a lot of sense if you are a man, but it turns out the way many women travel is very different. Women have these more complicated travel patterns which are called trip chaining. So for example, a typical travel day for a woman might involve dropping the kids off at school before she goes to work, picking up some groceries on the way home, maybe dropping in on an elderly relative.
你可以从大多数城市的布局中看出这一点，主干道通往市中心内外，这就是所谓的动脉系统，如果你是个男人，这非常合理，但事实证明，许多女性的出行方式却大不相同。女性拥有更复杂的出行模式，被称为“多目的地出行”（trip chaining）。例如，女性典型的一天出行可能包括：上班前送孩子上学、在回家的路上买点杂货，也许还要顺便看望一位年迈的亲戚。
And so women are much more likely to be walking, and women are also much more likely to use public transport, going on these local roads rather than just directly to a commercial area. When Carl's Goga Snow Plowing Schedule was first designed, all this trip chaining done by women simply wasn't factored in, because it wasn't considered work. But actually, this work contributes hugely to GDP. In fact, they discovered that if you put all the unpaid care work travel together, it turned out that travel for those purposes was almost as much as travel for paid work. And suddenly, if you collect data in that way,
因此，女性更有可能步行，也更有可能使用公共交通，她们会走这些地方道路，而不是直接前往商业区。当卡尔斯库加最初设计除雪时间表时，女性的所有这些“多目的地出行”根本没有被考虑在内，因为这不被视为工作。但事实上，这项工作对 GDP 的贡献巨大。事实上，他们发现，如果把所有无偿护理工作的出行加起来，就会发现这些目的地的出行量几乎与带薪工作的出行量不相上下。突然之间，如果你以这种方式收集数据，
suddenly becomes a totally different proposition. Once the city planner started looking at the data through the lens of gender, suddenly the idea that the city of Krooskoga Sweden should plow its major arteries first didn't make intuitive sense. Because that's really, really great for getting in and out of downtown. But it's not very good for traveling between different suburbs, which is the kind of travel that women are much more likely to do. So the city council of K Carl Skokka, realizing that it's harder to push a buggy through three inches of snow than it is to drive a car, decided to flip their snow clearing policy
它瞬间就变成了完全不同的命题。一旦城市规划者开始通过性别的视角来看待这些数据，瑞典卡尔斯库加市应该优先清理主干道这一想法就变得不再符合直觉了。因为这对于进出市中心确实非常非常棒。但对于不同郊区之间的出行却很不友好，而这正是女性更有可能进行的出行方式。因此，卡尔斯库加市议会意识到，推着婴儿车在三英寸深的雪地里跋涉比开车要难得多，于是他们决定彻底颠覆除雪政策，
on its head. From now on, it would be the minor streets and sidewalks that were plowed first, followed by the major arteries. What they didn't expect was it would actually save the money because it turned out that it dramatically reduced the admissions into accident and emergency because they were right. It is much easier to drive a car a few three inches of snow than to push a buggy and pedestrians were massively dominating admissions into accident and emergency and women were dominating the pedestrians. And so by this simple thing of changing the ordering which they cleared the snow, they
将其彻底反转。从现在开始，将优先清理小街道和人行道，然后才是主干道。他们没有想到的是，这实际上会省钱，因为事实证明，这大幅减少了急诊室的入院人数，因为他们是对的。开着车穿过三英寸深的雪地，比推着婴儿车要容易得多，而行人占了急诊室入院人数的绝大多数，其中女性又占了行人的绝大多数。因此，通过改变除雪顺序这一简单的举措，他们
had this dramatic effect on their health care bill. And that was not an insignificant cost. You know, one analysis found that it was three times the cost of the winter road maintenance. But the point of the story isn't that Carl's goga has saved money or even that women suffered fewer injuries. It's that the snow-cleaning policy had been poorly designed even though the city planners had started out with the best of intentions. You know, it's not like the travel planners thought, I know, let's make women fall over and fracture their pelvis. That'll be really funny. They just preceded along the presumption that what would have worked for them would just work for society.
对医疗保健开支产生了巨大的影响。这可不是一笔小数目。你知道，一项分析发现，这笔费用是冬季道路维护费用的三倍。但这个故事的重点不是卡尔斯库加省了钱，甚至不是女性受伤人数减少。而是除雪政策原本设计得很糟糕，尽管城市规划者最初是出于好意。你知道，并不是说交通规划者心里想的是：我知道，让我们让女性摔倒并骨盆骨折吧。那一定超级搞笑。他们只是带着一种假设行事，即对他们管用的方法对整个社会也同样管用。
You know, and when the snow clearing schedule was devised, you know, it would have been men coming up with that schedule and it did work for them. But they forgot, as happens so often in public policy, to remember that women exist. And this goes all the way back to the fact that, you know, this isn't just transport infrastructure. This is pretty much everything. Today I'm talking with Caroline Criado Perez about the largest and most persistent data gap in history, the failure to collect data on and from women when designing almost anything
你知道的，当除雪时间表制定出来时，制定这个时间表的人肯定是男性，而且它对他们确实管用。但正如在公共政策中经常发生的那样，他们忘记了女性也是存在的。这可以追溯到一个事实，即这不仅仅是交通基础设施的问题。这几乎适用于所有事物。今天我与卡罗琳·克里亚多·佩雷斯探讨了历史上最大、最根深蒂固的数据空白——在设计几乎所有东西时，都未能收集关于女性以及来自女性的数据，
and the consequences of that, not just for women, but for everyone. So, you talk about this a lot in your book, which is that at the root of almost all these design problems, which don't seem to take women to account, is the fallacy of the default male, the idea that when we picture a kind of default human, when we design something, whether we collect it or not, we picture a cis man. Were there times in your research where you discovered that you, yourself, were making a default male assumption?
以及由此带来的后果，不仅对女性，对所有人都是如此。所以，你在书中经常谈到这一点，那就是几乎所有这些似乎没有将女性考虑在内的设计问题的根源，都是“默认男性谬误”（the fallacy of the default male），即当我们设计某种东西时，无论我们是否收集数据，在我们脑海中构想某种默认人类时，我们构想的都是一个顺性别男性。在你的研究中，有没有发现你自己其实也在默认男性假设的时候？
Absolutely. I mean, that's kind of how I got into feminism in the first place, was realizing that I had this male default in my head, that whenever I pictured anyone and the gender wasn't specified, I was picturing a man. So, you know, a lawyer, a doctor, a journalist, a scientist, you know, anyone I was constantly picturing men. And that was really shocking to me because not only the fact that I was doing that, but also the fact that I hadn't noticed I was doing it, because it is really shocking. How would I not notice? I'm a woman. How would I not notice? There was always picturing the opposite sex. You know, that's just weird. And so we really are so used to seeing men as
当然有。我的意思是，这也是我最初接触女权主义的原因，我意识到自己脑海里有这种男性的默认设定，每当我脑海中浮现出某个人且没有指定性别时，我脑海里浮现的都是个男人。所以，你知道的，律师、医生、记者、科学家，你知道的，我脑海中不断浮现的任何人都是男人。这让我感到非常震惊，不仅因为我一直在这样做，还因为我竟然没有注意到自己在这样做，因为这真的很震惊。我怎么会没注意到呢？我是个女人。我怎么会没注意到？脑海里总是浮现出异性。你知道的，这太奇怪了。所以我们真的太习惯把男性视为
the default that most people aren't aware that they are ignoring women. But for people who are developing tech, for people who are developing workplace policy, for people who are developing medical research, you know, I wrote this book to kind of try and wake those people up because research. You know, I wrote this book to kind of try and wake those people up because I don't think that they are bad people, but by not collecting sex-d disaggregated data, what they are doing is having really serious negative, potentially fatal results for women. Well, you mentioned medical research. How is the absence of women in data gathering effect medicine? So, basically, the vast majority of medical research, and therefore, the vast majority of knowledge we have is based on the male body.
默认设定，以至于大多数人都没有意识到他们在忽视女性。但对于开发科技的人、开发职场政策的人、开发医学研究的人来说，你知道，我写这本书就是为了试图唤醒这些人，因为研究。你知道，我写这本书就是为了试图唤醒这些人，因为我不认为他们是坏人，但由于不收集按性别分类的数据，他们正在给女性带来非常严重、潜在致命的负面影响。好吧，你提到了医学研究。女性在数据收集中的缺失是如何影响医学的？所以，基本上，绝大多数医学研究，以及因此而来的绝大多数我们拥有的知识，都是基于男性身体得出的。
So, for all sorts of diseases, you know, because the way we have researched them, the way we treat them, the way we diagnose them has been based on research on men. Women get misdiagnosed. So for example heart attacks, women are more likely to die following a heart attack than men. And that's for a whole host of reasons. First of which is that female heart attack symptoms are not the heart attack symptoms that we have always been taught. So certainly I had always been taught that if I was having chest pain and pain down my left arm, I was having a heart attack. And it turns out that actually those are not the typical heart attack symptoms for women. Women are more likely to experience breathless, nausea, fatigue, what feels like indigestion.
所以，对于各种各样的疾病，你知道的，因为我们研究它们的方式、我们治疗它们的方式、我们诊断它们的方式，都是基于对男性的研究。女性常常被误诊。比如心脏病发作，女性心脏病发作后的死亡率高于男性。这背后有一系列原因。首先是女性心脏病发作的症状并不是我们一直被教导的心脏病发作症状。当然，我一直被教导的是，如果我胸痛并且左臂疼痛，我就是心脏病发作了。但事实证明，这些其实并不是女性典型的发作症状。女性更有可能经历气短、恶心、疲劳，感觉像是消化不良的症状。
And so women don't realize they're having heart attack so they don't go to the doctor. But even if they do go to the doctor, doctors don't realize that women are having a heart attack. But see, not all doctors don't realize, but there is this higher rate of misdiagnosis and it's partly because female heart attack symptoms are seen as atypical,
因此，女性没有意识到自己心脏病发作了，所以她们不会去看医生。但即使她们去看了医生，医生也没有意识到女性心脏病发作了。不过你看，并非所有医生都没意识到，但确实存在更高的误诊率，部分原因在于女性心脏病发作的症状被视为非典型症状，
even though they are very typical for women. And in fact, male heart attack symptoms are atypical for women. Only one in eight women will experience chest pain, for example. But we just, because of this way that we see men as the default, male heart attack symptoms are seen as the default. And female heart attack symptoms are seen as this kind of niche variant. I was just, was just stunning because if there was some kind of thing that affected, you know, 51% of the population, we wouldn't think that that is a niche problem. Yeah, but I mean, we do in all sorts of areas. I mean another area that that springs to mind is car crashes. So the car crash test dummy that has been used for decades
尽管这些症状对女性来说非常典型。事实上，男性的心脏病发作症状对女性来说才是非典型的。例如，每八名女性中只有一人会经历胸痛。但我们只是因为这种将男性视为默认设定的方式，把男性的心脏病发作症状视为默认标准。而女性的心脏病发作症状则被视为某种小众变体。这简直太惊人了，如果某种情况影响了，你知道的，51% 的人口，我们绝不会认为这是一个小众问题。是的，但我的意思是，我们在各个领域都这样做。我的另一个想到的领域是车祸。所以，几十年来一直用于
to test car safety has been based on a 50th percentile male. And obviously that is a problem. You know female bodies differ from male bodies in all sorts of ways. I mean we have fewer neck muscles, we have less upper body muscle mass. Our spinal columns are different, our pelvis is the different. You know, so these are all issues that need to be taken into account, but we've got this 50th percentile male dummy as if of course the 50th percentile male is the 50th percentile human. And actually what is quite in raging really is that when this was introduced
测试汽车安全性的碰撞测试假人一直是基于第 50 百分位数的男性。这显然是个问题。你知道的，女性身体在各方面都与男性身体不同。我的意思是，我们的颈部肌肉较少，上半身肌肉质量较少。我们的脊柱不同，骨盆也不同。你知道的，这些都是需要考虑的问题，但我们却有一个第 50 百分位数的男性假人，就好像第 50 百分位数的男性理所当然就是第 50 百分位数的人类一样。实际上，真正令人愤怒的是，当这个假人在
in the 1950s there was actually a debate about having a female crash test dummy, but as happens so often car manufacturers lobbied against it on the basis that it would be too expensive. In presumably, it doesn't just affect the safety data we collected, it actually affects the design of the car. Exactly. And the result is that cars just don't fit women very well. So for example, the seatbelt hasn't been designed to accommodate women's breasts.
20世纪50年代被引入时，其实曾就是否应该拥有一个女性碰撞测试假人展开过辩论，但正如经常发生的那样，汽车制造商对此进行了游说反对，理由是成本太高。想必，这不仅影响了我们收集的安全数据，实际上还影响了汽车的设计。没错。其结果就是汽车根本不适合女性。例如，安全带的设计并没有考虑到女性的乳房。
We haven't developed a seatbelt that accounts for pregnancy. Similarly, women need to sit much further forward than men in order to reach the pedals, obviously quite an important part of being able to drive. But that moves women out of what's called the standard seating position, and it puts them at a much higher risk in a frontal collision. And all of this together means that women are 47% more likely to be seriously injured, and 17% more likely to die than a man if they're in a car crash. And so that is negligence, but I think it gets even worse, because sort of belatedly regulators have realized that women do exist. In 2011, the US
我们没有开发出能够适应怀孕的安全带。同样，为了够到踏板，女性需要比男性坐得靠前得多，这显然是能够驾驶汽车的重要组成部分。但这把女性移出了所谓的标准驾驶坐姿，使她们在发生正面碰撞时面临更高的风险。所有这一切加起来意味着，如果在车祸中，女性受重伤的可能性比男性高 47%，死亡率高 17%。所以这是一种疏忽，但我认为情况甚至更糟，因为监管机构直到后知后觉才意识到女性确实存在。2011年，美国
realized that women exist and in 2015, the EU realized that women existed. You mean they finally introduced female grass-stuffies? Yeah, but I mean, they haven't really realized that women exist because actually the car crash test dummy that they are using is not anthropometrically correct. It's a scaled down male dummy. Right. But even worse than that, in the EU, this scaled down male dummy is only used in one
意识到女性的存在，而在2015年，欧盟意识到女性的存在。你是说他们终于引入了女性碰撞测试假人？是的，但我的意思是，他们并没有真正意识到女性的存在，因为实际上他们使用的汽车碰撞测试假人并不符合人体测量学。它是一个缩小版的男性假人。没错。但更糟糕的是，在欧盟，这个缩小版的男性假人只在五个监管测试中的一个
out of the five regulatory tests, and only in the passenger seat. So basically all you can say based on those tests is that we have data on whether it's safe or not for scaled down men to sit in the passenger seat. So basically all you can say based on those tests is that we have data on whether it's safe or not for scaled down men to sit in the passenger seat. But we do have data on whether it's safe actual women to sit in the passenger seat and no data at all on what it's like for someone who might be slightly similar to a woman to drive. Things like snow plowing and medical protocols and car safety are just a few instances where there is a critical data gap Either because there is no data on women or the data that exists is not sex-desaggregated
中被使用，而且只在乘客座位上使用。所以基本上根据这些测试，你只能说我们拥有关于缩小版男性坐在乘客座位上是否安全的数据。所以基本上根据这些测试，你只能说我们拥有关于缩小版男性坐在乘客座位上是否安全的数据。但我们拥有关于真实女性坐在乘客座位上是否安全的数据，而对于像女性那样的人开车会是什么情况，则完全没有数据。诸如除雪、医疗方案和汽车安全只是存在严重数据鸿沟的几个例子，要么是因为缺乏关于女性的数据，要么是因为现有的数据没有按性别分类。
Even something as innocuous as the width of a piano key has been designed only with male hand sizes in mind In militaries across the world in mind. In militaries across the world, marching regulations have been designed based solely on the average male stride length, with disastrous results for female recruits. Construction tools, safety equipment, building codes, smartphones, voice recognition software, all of it designed using a corpus of data in which women largely do not exist. But after this break, we'll look at another example that might just provide a blueprint for how to do things better in the future. I've been talking to Caroline Criado Perez about her book Invisible Women, and of all the stories of poor design based on the gender data gap that Caroline told me, perhaps the most instructive
甚至连钢琴键的宽度这样看似无害的东西，在设计时也只考虑了男性手的大小。世界各地的军队也是如此，行军条例完全根据普通男性的步幅设计，给女性新兵带来了灾难性的后果。施工工具、安全设备、建筑规范、智能手机、语音识别系统，所有这一切的设计所依据的数据库中，女性基本上是不存在的。但在休息之后，我们将探讨另一个例子，它可能为未来如何做得更好提供蓝图。我一直在和卡罗琳·克里亚多·佩雷斯谈论她的书《被隐形的女性》，在卡罗琳告诉我的所有基于性别数据鸿沟的糟糕设计的故事中，也许最具启示意义的
was the case of the Three Stone Stove.. The three stone stove is a traditional form of cooking that's used by 80% of people in the developing world, and it is what it sounds like. Three stones arranged in a circle on the ground with a pot placed on top of them and a fire underneath. And the problem with this type of stove is that the fumes that are given off are incredibly toxic. And it's not just that the fumes are really toxic. It's how long women and children are exposed to the fumes,
就是“三石灶”（Three Stone Stove）的案例。三石灶是一种传统的烹饪方式，发展中国家 80% 的人都在使用它，正如其名。三块石头在地面上围成一圈，上面放着一口锅，下面生着火。这种炉子的一个问题是，它释放的烟雾毒性极大。不仅仅是烟雾毒性极大，更在于女性和儿童暴露在烟雾中的时间有多长，
because also the three stone stove is not very efficient. So they will be in a poorly ventilated room being exposed to, I think, one estimate with something like the equivalent of more than a hundred cigarettes per day. And this seems like something like we've had stovets and ovens for quite a long time. Why wasn't this fixed a long time ago? Did we even try? Yeah. So there have been attempts by development agencies to develop these clean stovets that don't require you to be hooked up to the national grid. But we still have this big problem that they aren't being adopted and the reason that they aren't being adopted is incredibly simple.
因为三石灶的效率也不是很高。所以她们会待在一个通风不良的房间里，暴露在相当于（据我所知的一项估计）每天吸一百多支烟的环境中。这似乎是那种我们已经拥有炉灶和烤箱很久的东西。为什么这个问题没有在很久以前得到解决？我们甚至尝试过吗？是的。因此，发展机构曾试图开发这些不需要连接国家电网的清洁炉灶。但我们仍然面临一个大问题，那就是它们没有被采用，而没有被采用的原因极其简单。
It's that they are being designed without anyone going and speaking to women and asking them what they need and what they want. How are they lacking the current designs? The issues, I mean they're just sort of hilariously basic. They keep developing stoves that for example increase cooking time. Now women are already cooking for five hours a day. They don't have more time to spend cooking. Also they often require more attending. And again, you know, when you're having to spend so long cooking, you need to be able to multitask. And again, this isn't something that has been factored in. One clean cook stove was developed and they, it required a certain amount of maintenance. And the designers just sort of assumed,
那就是在设计它们时，没有任何人去和女性交流，询问她们需要什么以及想要什么。目前的设计到底缺乏什么？这些问题，我的意思是它们只是那种荒谬的基础。他们一直在开发的炉灶，例如会增加烹饪时间。现在女性每天已经要花五个小时做饭了。她们没有更多的时间花在做饭上。此外，它们通常需要更多的照看。同样，你知道的，当你不得不花这么长时间做饭时，你需要能够同时处理多项任务。这也是一个没有被考虑进去的因素。曾开发过一款清洁炉灶，并且需要一定程度的维护。设计人员只是想当然地认为，
oh, well, the household will take care of that. But actually, maintenance in that way was a man's job. And the men didn't want to maintain these stoves because they thought, well, why do I need to, you know, she can just cook on the old style of stove. So why do I want to waste my time maintaining the stove? Another one was, you one was a similar issue that the stove was too small to just put bits of wooden.
哦，好吧，家里人会处理好的。但实际上，这种维护是男人的工作。而男人们不想维护这些炉灶，因为他们觉得，为什么我要做这些，你知道的，她可以用旧式的炉灶做饭啊。那我为什么要浪费时间去维护这个炉灶呢？另一个问题是，其中一个炉灶有类似的问题，就是炉灶太小，无法直接放入木柴。
You had to chop the wood up. Again, that was a man's job. They weren't doing it. So the women didn't get to use these stoves. There's all these really, really simple things that should have been caught at the design stage. If they had just gone and spoken to the women and said, you know, what do you need? And they would have
你必须把木柴劈小。同样，那是男人的工作。他们不干。所以女性根本没法用这些炉灶。所有这些真的非常非常简单的事情，本应该在设计阶段就被发现的。如果他们只是去和女性交流，问问她们，你知道的，你们需要什么？然后她们就会
said, well, we need something that means that we don't have to spend more time cooking, that we can look after our kids while we're doing it, and that we don't need men to help us with because they won't. And so, program after program for year after year has failed for these really, really basic reasons. And how many years are we talking about? Well, decades. And the really frustrating thing is that often reports get produced that basically say that it's the women's fault, you know, the women are unwilling to learn how to use the staves or the women are choosing to cook in these dangerous toxic fumes. That one really is just insulting. Yeah, I mean, this reminds me of all this language in the crash tests that women are the out of position drivers. It really does, there's a moment where
说，我们需要一种不需要我们花更多时间做饭、做饭时还能照顾孩子、并且不需要男人帮忙的东西，因为他们根本不会帮忙。因此，由于这些非常非常基础的原因，一个又一个项目年复一年地失败了。我们说的是多少年？嗯，几十年。真正令人沮丧的是，经常会有报告出炉，基本上把责任归咎于女性，你知道的，女性不愿意学习如何使用炉灶，或者女性选择在这些危险的有毒烟雾中做饭。那个真的太侮辱人了。是的，我的意思是，这让我想起碰撞测试中的所有那些用语，说什么女性是“姿势不当的驾驶员”。确实如此，有那么一刻，
And it really does, like there's a moment where designers and people studying this finally see women and that is trying to find someone to blame. Yeah, I mean, I sort of connect this to the default male because this position of, well, there must be something wrong with the women. We've got to fix the women. That never is actually something that we apply to men. And I think it becomes most clear when you are looking at things like, workplace initiatives where the idea is,
确实如此，比如有一刻，设计人员和研究这些问题的人终于看到了女性，那就是在试图找人背锅的时候。是的，我的意思是，我将此与默认男性联系起来，因为这种观点，即“女性一定有什么问题，我们必须修复女性”。这其实是我们从来不会对男性应用的东西。我认为当你看一些诸如职场倡议之类的事情时，这一点最明显，其核心观点是，
oh, well, we need to build up women's confidence. It's that women aren't confident enough that that's why they're not getting promoted. That's why they're not going for promotions. that's why they're not choosing XYZ subject. And yet, study after study has shown that actually women are pretty good at assessing their skill, their intelligence, and actually it's men who tend to overestimate their skill and intelligence. And so when you see that, then you sort of have to think, well, maybe it's not that the women rate themselves too low. It's the men rating themselves too
哦，好吧，我们需要建立女性的自信心。就是因为女性不够自信，所以她们才得不到晋升。这就是为什么她们不去争取晋升。这就是为什么她们不选择某某学科。然而，一项又一项的研究表明，实际上女性在评估自己的技能和智力方面相当擅长，而实际上往往是男性高估了自己的技能和智力。所以当你看到这一点时，你就会想，也许不是女性对自己评价过低，而是男性对自己评价过
high. But just we just never think of it like that. You know, because the male is the default, it's assumed, well, that must be the right level. Right. And the women are wrong. So we got to fix the women. So did anyone bother to design a stove based primarily on the input of women and and if so what what did they create? They did. It has a happy ending. So yeah, a few years ago, research is an India instead of trying to create a whole stove. They created this this device that you can put on any cook stove and And basically, it cuts wood use and cuts smoke to comparable levels. It's very, very cheap. It's used with recycled metal material.
太高了。但我们只是从来没有这样想过。你知道的，因为男性是默认设定，人们就会理所当然地认为，那一定就是正确的水平。没错。而女性是错的。所以我们必须纠正女性。那么，有没有人费心去主要根据女性的意见来设计炉灶呢？如果有，她们创造出了什么？有的。它有一个美好的结局。所以，是的，几年前，印度的研究人员没有试图制造整个炉灶，而是创造了这个可以放在任何炉灶上的装置，
And it's being picked up not just in India. There have been studies in Kenya and Ghana with the same device with similarly positive results that women are adopting this. And basically, guess how they found out how to do this. They asked women. Went and they asked women. It's revolutionary.
基本上，它将木柴消耗量和烟雾减少到了相当的水平。它非常非常便宜。它是用回收的金属材料制成的。不仅在印度受到了欢迎。肯尼亚和加纳也对同一装置进行了研究，结果同样积极，女性正在采用这种装置。基本上，你猜她们是怎么知道如何做到这一点的。她们去问了女性。她们去问了女性。这简直是革命性的。
So what these researchers did that was different was they started off from the basis of what do women actually need, what do women actually want, how can we provide that. And so the researchers went and asked the women, you know, what is the issue, rather than coming in from above and saying, you women, you know, are very silly and naughty, use the stove. I mean, when I read your book, it's kind of both satisfying and enraging about it is that the solution is pretty simple, you know. it's just talk to women, gather data, and think of that while you're making things or include women in the process the whole time.
所以这些研究人员所做的与众不同的事情是，他们从女性实际需要什么、女性实际想要什么、我们如何提供这些东西出发。因此，研究人员去询问女性，你知道的，问题出在哪里，而不是居高临下地说，你们这些女性，你知道的，非常愚蠢和淘气，快用这个炉灶吧。我的意思是，当我读你的书时，既感到满意又感到愤怒的是，解决方案其实很简单，你知道的。就是和女性交谈、收集数据，并在制造东西时考虑到这一点，或者在整个过程中让女性参与进来。
Do you find yourself hopeful, just the spirited angry? Oh, I feel really angry. I am incredibly pissed off. Yeah. I am incredibly pissed off. Yeah, because it's so frustrating. And particularly when it comes to areas where I know that researchers know that there is a problem. Yeah.
你觉得自己充满希望，还是只是满腔怒火？哦，我感到非常愤怒。我简直气炸了。是的。我简直气炸了。是的，因为这太令人沮丧了。特别是当谈到那些我知道研究人员明明知道存在问题的领域时。是的。
And, you know, I mean, I often get asked, you know, what's the most shocking thing you found? And I understand why people ask that know, what's the most shocking thing you found? And I understand why people ask that question, it's an obvious question to ask, because there are so many shocking things. But because there are so many shocking things, it's quite difficult to pick on. You know, like a shot, yeah. And actually, also, after a while, you become sort of numb to it, because it's also awful. And, you know, women are dying in car crashes, women are dying from heart attacks, women are dying from unclean cook stoves. So after a while it's not the examples, it's the excuses that make you really angry. And to this day, I've had, let's say not entirely friendly exchanges on Twitter
而且，你知道的，我经常被问到，你发现的最令人震惊的事情是什么？我理解为什么人们会问那个问题，这是一个显而易见的问题，因为有太多令人震惊的事情了。但正因为有太多令人震惊的事情，所以很难挑出一件。你知道的，就像挑出一件最震撼的事一样，是的。而且事实上，过了一段时间后，你就会变得有点麻木了，因为这一切都太糟糕了。而且，你知道的，女性死于车祸，女性死于心脏病，女性死于不清洁的炉灶。所以过了一段时间后，让你真正愤怒的不是那些例子，而是各种借口。直到今天，我还曾在推特上进行过，
with certain researchers who actually say, well, we can't test on women because they have periods. And that would complicate the results. And that's just in raging because they must know, as I know, that yes, periods do in fact have an impact on results. That's right, that's the whole thing. That's something that you need to know. And yet, you know, 2019, and I have medical researchers, you know, trying the, oh well, we'll start in men, and if we find anything interesting, then we'll include women. Which again, is positioning male as the default.
可以说是算不上友好的交流，对象是一些研究人员，他们竟然说，嗯，我们不能在女性身上进行测试，因为她们有月经。那会使结果变得复杂。这真的让人很愤怒，因为他们一定知道，正如我所知的那样，是的，月经确实对结果有影响。没错，这就是全部的重点。这是你需要了解的事情。然而，你知道的，已经是 2019 年了，我还看到医学研究人员试图用这种说辞，“哦，好吧，我们先从男性开始，如果我们发现任何有趣的东西，那么我们再把女性纳进来”。这再次将男性定位为默认设定。
And I suppose one of the things that makes me most angry is that it's sort of thinking about how many drugs for women have we missed out on because they didn't work for men when we started testing them. Do you see the end of excuses or like, is this, I mean, are we reaching an end where you can no longer have these excuses or is this still just as bad as ever? Um, well, we're definitely not reaching an end. Um, yeah, I'm not trying to make you have a good view of this at all. Like, I do, I do, I do, I do, I do your pessimism.
我想最让我愤怒的一点是，我们在想，有多少针对女性的药物，因为我们在开始测试时它们对男性不管用，从而被我们错过了？你看到了借口终结的迹象吗？或者说，我的意思是，我们是否正在迎来一个再也不能有这些借口的时候，还是说这种情况依然和以前一样糟糕？嗯，我们绝对没有迎来终结。嗯，是的，我并不是想让你对这个有任何好的看法。真的，我，我，我，我，我理解你的悲观。
Um, yeah, so I, I, I tell you what, you know, you asked me, how did I feel writing the book and writing the book, I felt absolutely despondent. Since the book has come out, I have felt more hope. And that has been because the response has been actually quite incredible from both men and women. Women, the main response and reaction has just been one of relief of, wow, the world suddenly makes sense. And I've realized that there isn't something wrong with me. I just have a body that hasn't been factored
嗯，所以我，我，我告诉你吧，你知道的，你问我，我写这本书时的感觉是什么，写这本书时，我感到彻底绝望。自从这本书出版以来，我感到了更多的希望。那是因为来自男性和女性的反应实际上都相当不可思议。女性的主要回应和反应只是一种解脱，哇，这个世界突然变得合理了。我意识到并不是我身上有什么问题。我只是拥有一个在几乎所有事物的设计中都没有被考虑进去的身体。
into the design of pretty much anything. But also from men, I've had so many men get in touch telling me about how they are changing their hiring procedure and how they are changing their research procedure and how they are changing buildings that they're designing, incorporating what they have read in the book into the way that they work, projects what they have read in the book into the way that they work projects that they are involved in. So if you were to prescribe a solution, you know, to make this better, what are the specialties?
但同样来自男性，我有那么多的男性联系我，告诉我他们是如何改变招聘程序的，他们是如何改变研究程序的，他们是如何改变他们正在设计的建筑的，将他们在书中读到的内容融入到他们工作的方式中，融入到他们参与的项目中。所以如果你要开出一剂药方，你知道的，为了让这一切变得更好，具体有哪些？
Oh, you know what my answer's going to be. Well, let's go for the answer. Collect, sex, disaggregated data. You know, because it really is that simple. It is that simple. It is that simple. And actually, an amazing thing that happened yesterday was, you know, and I think this is perhaps my biggest win to date, was that the Scottish government have started a working group on collecting sex and gender-disaggregated data as a result of the book. And that was,
哦，你知道我的答案会是什么。好吧，让我们听听答案。收集按性别分类的数据。你知道的，因为事情就是这么简单。就是这么简单。就是这么简单。实际上，昨天发生了一件令人惊叹的事情，你知道的，而且我认为这可能是我迄今为止最大的胜利，那就是苏格兰政府由于这本书的影响，成立了一个关于收集性别分类数据的工作小组。那就是，
I mean, that's just amazing. Oh yeah, God loves Scots. They are great and I'm going to have to move there because when we Brexit, Scotland is going to be the only safe haven. save haven. Caroline Criado Perez's book is called Invisible Women Data Bias in a World Design for Met. It's available wherever books are sold and I highly recommend you go out and buy a copy because it's filled with hundreds of other examples of gendered data bias that will have you questioning the default cis man design assumptions of the world around you. It's truly illuminating and infuriating and inspiring all at the same time. 99% Invisible's impact design coverage is supported by Autodesk. Autodesk
我的意思是，这简直太棒了。哦，是的，上帝保佑苏格兰人。他们太棒了，我得搬到那里去，因为当我们脱欧时，苏格兰将成为唯一的避难所。避难所。卡罗琳·克里亚多·佩雷斯的书名为《被隐形的女性：数据偏见如何塑造了一个专为男性设计的世界》。这本书在各大书店均有销售，我强烈建议大家去买一本，因为它里面充满了数百个其他性别数据偏见的例子，会让你质疑你周围世界中默认顺性别男性设计的假设。它真的既具启示性、又令人愤怒、同时又鼓舞人心。99% Invisible 的影响力设计报道得到了 Autodesk 的支持。Autodesk
supports the design and creation of innovative solutions to the world's most pressing social and environmental challenges. Autodesk Foundation is a proud partner of 60 decibels. 60 decibels makes it easy to listen to the people who matter most. Their lean data approach turns customer voice into high value insights that help businesses grow and maximize their impact. They leverage the power of technology to communicate directly with marginalized communities, collecting high-quality impact data efficiently at a fraction of the time of traditional approaches. That means businesses providing everything from off-grid energy solutions to family health services
支持为世界上最紧迫的社会和环境挑战设计和创造创新的解决方案。Autodesk 基金会是 60 Decibels 的自豪合作伙伴。60 Decibels 让倾听最重要的人的声音变得容易。他们精简的数据方法将客户的声音转化为高价值的洞察，帮助企业发展并将其影响力最大化。他们利用技术的力量与边缘化社区直接沟通，以传统方法一小部分的时间，高效地收集高质量的影响力数据。这意味着企业提供从离网能源解决方案到家庭健康服务的各种内容，
can better understand their customers, adapt to their needs, and do more good. To learn more, you can visit 60desibles.com or go to Autodesk.com slash Redshift to explore more on the future of making. to The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, senior editor-genilini hall, Sheree Fusef, Avery Troll from Envivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, run Instagram and read it
都能更好地了解他们的客户，适应他们的需求，并做得更多。要了解更多信息，您可以访问 60decibels.com 或前往 Autodesk.com/Redshift 探索更多关于创造未来的内容。团队的其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、高级编辑杰尼利妮·霍尔（Genينيli Hall）、谢里·菲塞夫（Sheree Fusef）、艾弗里·特罗尔（Avery Troll）、恩维维安·利（Envivian Lee）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的 Radio Row。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚定独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上 @ 我 @RomanMars，或 @本节目 @99PI org，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到我们。
too. But if you want to comment on your least favorite examples of gender bias and design, you can do that at 99pi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但是，如果你想对你最不喜欢的性别偏见和设计的例子发表评论，你可以在 99pi.org 上进行。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。